thank you yasser here we have a very
theoretical draw between levonadonian
with black and fabiano carnotellas
how deep did you know all of this
yeah
i've lost one time like this against
fabiano in a the game and twenty two
yeah
and then i kind of said okay i have to
study this line as well
and well it's so it's a very funny line
actually you know uh
i mean there is this i i'm i will show
some cheapo for yes sir yeah if you go
back
instead of king uh to
c2
yeah king b2 is the move and then there
is rook fd8
so rook hd1
i think it's e4
and uh let's say white goes ruth has d8
rook takes d8
rook takes d8
d8 and let's say c4
i mean it's probably with king b3 first
but anyway
black has this idea f5
and king b3
there is this nice move bishop h4
wow g3 of four yeah yes
this is for you my dear yes sir
that's gorgeous
and so bishop c1 e3 and black is fine
and it's just fine
maybe even better even better right
probably better yeah yeah
but wow what a line
yeah you have this subtleties i mean you
have to know them and king c2 of course
is the most principled move
and it forces black to you know pay
attention
but
i knew that it's a bit passive but uh
you know i have my play we are yana
ponichi on the show since they finished
so early mentioned that this move a5 he
also knew that he was also important uh
when did you discover this move a5
when i pressed the spacebar
love it a correct answer
he played this move after rook v8 check
it seemed that rook did somehow rattled
him and i think king d3 is not the move
i think a5 is the move a5 right away
yeah and black has to you know pay a
little bit attention i think first you
need to play f6 king f7
then
it's a draw i mean black has enough
counter play white is not in time to
push
but after king d3 i started getting some
hopes because i thought well my route
gets active you never know because
yeah i
well he has to probably play king c2
were you surprised because he did we
thought king e4 here in the studio but
what after rookie eight you go back
but rookie six is you know you
you get nervous about this type of thing
i think at this point he was already
nervous after king d3 yeah yeah
because you know you don't know i mean
if you take in c5 probably there is
enough activity for white but
it's a pawn after all it is so in the
game he went back and you didn't repeat
you thought
maybe i can start pressing yeah i knew
that there is
nothing for black but i just thought you
know
just to keep some pressure in the game
you know it's a chance and after h4 well
the only thing i calculated i mean after
this rook d4 stuff that
uh somehow um
a5h for king b3
i'm faster than him rook d3 king a4 g3
takes and rook g2 rook a8
king h7 a6 and bishop g1
and somehow i'm faster because
c5 i have
a2
uh uh
sorry maybe it's through or okay too or
okay too yeah
and then king b3 h3 yeah h3 and you are
promoting upon yes
yeah you're promoting your phone maybe
it's our h3 first
somehow it was all working for me yeah
h3 and remedial and then we're k2 yeah
wow a lot to consider um yeah because
rook h8 is impossible i take a7 and then
i take on a3 it's like checkers and i
collect all the phones show me again
like this one goes through
rocket right here
right away uh-huh yeah
thanks it's like checkers yeah ah yes
i see it rigorous of a3 covering the a
file takes takes but bishop takes c5 and
you collect everything yeah very nice so
it did seem like it got a little
dangerous for him but always yeah but
the rook a6 was a good move
and
what i realized is that if i take well i
have to take on c4 because now rook g4
um
there is i mean he's faster i think now
he doesn't need to
well he doesn't need to put the king in
awkward position right on we're trying
to calculate this we couldn't figure it
out yeah so how does this go
i thought he would give a check
uh king a7 and a6
takes and takes king b3 bishop g1 bishop
g1
um
with eight seventeen yeah a7 he can do
yeah
you have to take it right i don't think
rook g3 helps you
i don't think here it does
and then well he is in time with bishop
d6
right
h3 bishop d6 even just not playing c5 at
all even okay one maybe you know
yeah also yeah this can get tricky it's
gonna get tricky because he still has a
pawn yeah and then after i taking v3
that the issue is i cannot go rook c8
because uh he has bishop e1
ah that's annoying and this bonus and if
i commit with g5 then you know
after bishop c3 or bishop d2 i mean the
pawns just get too loose
and the rook is too active and if i go
rook g4 instead of rook c1
i think the issue here is rook c6
yes
and after i i take
he can go a6 bishop g1 bishop c5
and i think it's a draw it's a draw
button you're not pushing for a win on
this one no no all right so you went for
rook c1 and he played bishop c3 and it
said it seemed that king h7 rook a7 was
finally yeah yeah now now it seems he
gets enough counter play because my rook
is cut right
well fascinating theoretical duo uh for
you it seemed like you were just a one
move better prepared than favi is that
your feeling
no i think he knew that the position is
drawn i think his king d3 was just
a bit careless and then he had to
you know pay attention
not to get in trouble well but he paid
just about enough attention and i draw a
logical result seems like that's going
to be the
name of the game today for very logical
but good draws
yeah yeah i mean it's an extremely
exciting day
[Laughter]
we have some more decisive than others
well thank you levon for joining us here
in the studio two more games to go
thank you lavon thank you for the cheapo
that was very